foreign
as of hours ago Biden came through and
issued yet another
um executive order of some sort yeah
executive order of sorts yes issuing yet
more forgiveness for borrowers which in
the past we've been we've been seeing
these trickle through you know things
for disabled folks vets people who their
school went out of business and you know
I'm definitely not mad at that the one
that came through today 39 billion
dollars of forgiveness for around 804
000 borrowers and so of course
everybody's like Jade what does this
mean you know is this for everybody is
this for me you know what does this mean
and I'm like well if you really look at
it this is for folks John who signed up
for these income driven repayment plans
uh you might see it labeled as IDR and
you're like what the heck is an IDR plan
income driven repayment plans and these
are people John who have been paying
their student loans for the past 20 25
years
because they were told if you make this
payment for 20 years and you make x
amount of qualifying payments you'll at
the end of the road you'll have
forgiveness
25 years John
wow You'll have forgiveness and then you
get there you're sweaty you're tired
your body's aching your back is broken
and there was nothing and they say nah
we changed our mind and now finally
these folks are getting their money so
hey it's a good day for our parents
right if they have student loans for
real but
here's here's where I'm at and here's
for me where I think is just
it's just painful these these plans that
are for these folks 25 years in they're
like finally I'm getting my money these
are the same plans John that they want
borrowers today to get into because
student loan payments are coming up
you're gonna start have to start making
your payments in October right hey
we don't want you guys to have to pay
too much you know we don't want you
uncomfortable so why don't you jump into
one of these income driven repayment
plans uh the new one I believe is called
the save plan y'all can correct me if
I'm wrong they're always changing the
acronyms on this but the idea is hey you
can jump on the site you're
automatically enrolled when payments
come back and you can just jump on the
site and go ahead and um you can go
ahead and submit your own estimate of
your income and and we're not we're not
going to require any qualifying
documents to see if it's right so people
just gonna make up a number I make 30
grand and I can pay 15 come on that'll
be good and just kick that just kick
that can down the road for 20 25 30
years and at the end you know there'll
be a little Buckle of gold at that
rainbow except that in in
24 years we're going to have gone
through what six presidential
transitions come on 12 Senate
transitions who knows man and with the
data coming out yesterday there was
um folks are beginning to talk more and
more about the
psychological the mental health aspect
of owing people money yes and it it is
sleep inhibitory it messed up your sleep
it messed up your relationships it makes
you not want to live makes you don't
want to be married it makes all these
issues and so what we're saying is I
want you to be unwell for 20 years go to
the College of your choice and that you
feel most passionate about and study
what you want to study and just give us
a little bit every month choose to be
miserable yeah and not be fully present
because you have this hovering over your
head this black cloud as the article
said hovering over your head and then in
20 25 years if you're lucky we'll take
it from you yeah I mean John you you
painted a beautiful picture
um in an earlier segment there was a
caller who had a certain number of
students she had seventy thousand
dollars of student loan debt and she had
seventy thousand dollars of savings and
she was feeling some type of way about
using the savings to pay off the debts
project words were if I pay this off I'm
gonna feel like I'm broke
yeah and I was like you are bro you are
broke and like the picture that you
painted I thought was brilliant and I
kind of wanted to elaborate that it it
really is when when you have the money
sitting there to pay these loans guys
and you're not paying them it is like
you live in this beautiful home right
and and it's everything you want it's
modern it's it's got all the right
surfaces you know what I'm saying it's
got It's got the marble countertops but
outside right outside your home is a
black giant black hole desolation
destruction and you just ignore it every
day you have to stay in the house you
gotta stay in the house you can't go
anywhere you can't go outside because
but your brain knows it's there your
reality yeah your but your brain knows
the reality right that you owe the
government
this much money and I just
for me guys and I know you guys are like
Jade wow you don't have to yell about it
Jade or you're doing the most Jade and
and it's for you the the reason I get
mad about this is I care about you I
want the best for you I know how that
feels I I know how it feels to not be
able to sleep at night I know how it
feels to have that effect on your
marriage the way you work all the
decisions that you make are so that you
can pay bills that's that's a load of
crap man that's for the birds and I
don't want that for you the way I feel
about this is there are so many things
that want you to think that that has the
power but that's not true you have the
power but some of you guys are so
um I can't say that on the radio some of
you guys are so intent on being right
instead of being happy you'd rather be
right that the government owes me this
and they're the ones that will take care
of this mess and they need to figure it
out but I'm trying to give you the
answer that's going to make you happy
and give you peace and give you freedom
and that's you taking back your power
you taking back your autonomy right you
being able to just financially
self-regulate on your own instead of
depending on the government instead of
depending on credit cards instead of
depending on all those other external
factors to do what you can do for
yourself and I if you don't get nothing
else from this understand I want you to
be free I know you can be free and I
know you have inside of yourself the
power to be free period